[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
même moi j'en ai des plus modernes la
vérité tu ressemble pas à ça Harry
Potter mais en même temps tu lui
ressemble trop c'est très bizarre j'aime
pas du tout
je t'explique
[Rires]
sur l'échelle de la boule de City tu te
regardais la dernière fois je te
trouvais comme ça c'est pas mal frère tu
t'es effondré
d'insulter un handicapé je ne vois rien
qu'est-ce que tu voulais te dire
attends attends
il y a pas de correction bien sûr
[Rires]
est-ce que tu peux nous montrer un
étranglement il a déjà montré on va le
remontrer pour les téléspectateurs non
voilà est-ce que ça peut servir le MMA
dans la vie de tous les jours c'est à
dire que lui lui va essayer va
t'attaquer tu es dans la rue tu es
tranquillement en train de marcher et là
il va te dire euh il va il va te
bousculer donc là il va s'embrouiller
avec toi voilà vous faites la scène et
après là tu me les tringles et après tu
me le film au sol tu me le finis au sol
vas-y il frappait tout le monde
attention
j'irai à Québec
allez allez allez
[Applaudissements]
allez
viens essayer de le faire ce qu'il fait
[Rires]
parce que votre truc là vas-y maintenant
mais c'est pour montrer téléspectateurs
vas-y regarde regarde
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non non d'abord je voudrais voir un
petit étangle mort et après il va
t'amener au sol après 25 ans vas-y non
mais juste ça juste pour voir vas-y
regarde regarde voilà là là tu vois la
tête là la tête là avec la main avec la
main droite voilà comme ça et voilà et
là tu es en haut la tête avec nous voilà
voilà
[Rires]
c'est les veines qui pète en fait tu
m'as tué Gilles regarde regarde regarde
vas-y doucement alors vas-y qu'est-ce
que tu penses
quoi
un sentiment voilà là toujours voilà là
voilà là
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et tout j'ai des lunettes bravo merci
j'ai mal au cou j'ai mal là et il vient
de me péter la cuisse
on va la refaire si tu l'attaques
on va pas la taper il va lui apprendre
quelque chose c'est une vieille
hein
Daniel je veux qu'il lui apprenne
exactement Daniel vient mais c'est pour
t'apprendre tu vas faire sur quelqu'un
tu vas faire manger
[Rires]
avec Mansour c'est vrai que c'est en
train de cartonner c'est en train
d'exploser actuellement c'est un truc de
fou je sais moins c'est vraiment c'est
de la France
alors c'est quoi ton but là c'est de
gagner déjà ce tournoi ce tournoi et
tous les autres tournois qui existent
combien de fois par semaine
[Musique]
plusieurs fois enfin plusieurs fois par
jour il faut dire tu fais que ça c'est
vraiment c'est
un vrai métier c'est pas un truc c'est
pas loin de dire il faut le dire au
téléspectateurs c'est vraiment devenu un
truc de fou c'est tu t'entraînes tous
les jours
c'est normal je sais c'est ton métier ah
c'est un truc de fou comment tu fais
comment tu as démarré mon coach et on
voit son palier mais on est à la salle
des fessiers et depuis j'ai toujours
aimé tu as commencé par quoi comme sport
de combat je suis au départ d'accord
comme tout le monde hein
et beaucoup de mecs qui ont fait non
ouais
c'était c'est quand tu t'es dit je vais
y aller tu t'es tu t'es tu t'es motivé
direct c'est plus mes amis mais ma
famille qui ont plus encourager
c'est vraiment l'étoile montante je le
dis du MMA et tu vas gagner tu vas
arriver en demi et après c'est possible
après c'est parti est-ce que tu veux
faire un dernier combat contre Raymond
vraiment tu veux faire un dernier combat
par contre le
l'attaque pas le l'attaque
pas c'est vendredi
là c'est le 12 mai t'inquiète pas c'est
le 12 mai tu as le temps franchement
faut que je le mette au moins une fois
au sol mais non alors attends est-ce
qu'on peut faire une autre simulation on
peut faire un simulation thé au sol en
dessous est-ce que tu peux être au sol
tu es au sol il a pris l'ascendant sur
toi vas-y
c'est mieux debout
vas-y mets-toi sur lui moi tu as pris la
chance
[Musique]
maintenant vas-y maintenant fini le
grand chose
[Applaudissements]
on a la chance qui reste 2 minutes on
peut faire un dernier round
ce qu'il faut que tu passes est-ce que
tu veux Guillaume est-ce que tu veux
essayer avec mon tour
est-ce qu'on peut refaire il a la
sentence sur lui on va voir comment il
va s'endort
c'est compliqué parce que vraiment des
techniques dans le dos cette coupe
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
un dernier combat allez vas-y debout
mais par contre ne l'attaque pas tu
tournes autour tourne tourne l'attaque
pas vas-y merci
vas-y
non mais c'est ça vas-y vas-y réponds
vas-y tu me fatigues
[Applaudissements]
tu peux nous montrer alors est-ce que tu
peux nous montrer ce que tu as fait
autre chose que tu peux nous montrer ce
que tu as fait comment tu l'as attrapé
ou tu l'attrapé alors tu peux nous
montrer hein tu peux faire
ça va sinon
[Applaudissements]